let's not beat around the bush all right
are you in the halftime show
am I in a hat tent show I'm involved
with a lot of things I have to do with
the Super Bowl I just leave it at that
are you in the halftime show yeah
I plead the fifth under the right that
this question might incriminate me I
understand I know for a fact because I
was there when you came with JLo for the
opening of her show of her residency I
did the opening with Jennifer at a
residency I did the opening of the world
cup she came down there for us in Brazil
and South Paulo so you know I leave it
up I leave it up to the fans man that's
a beautiful thing about democracy yeah
vote for it and you get it you who are
connected so let me just say this yes I
get out - I'm very proud of both of them
yeah yeah so say if you know you might
be involved this is hypothetical this is
me just being crazy yeah if you were
involved what would it mean to be on
that stage on the biggest stage in
American television the biggest stage on
American television it's always an honor
you know like I said I'm involved with a
lot of things in the Super Bowl and it's
an honor to have the Super Bowl down
here in Miami but I would take that
amazing opportunity and then I step to
the NFL and I say okay now let's talk
about me having a piece of Miami
Dolphins
really do you want a piece of the doll
yeah who are you going for the Super
Bowl I said adolphus yeah yeah yeah
Kevin Hodges told me all right good luck
in 2096 what I believe in y'all don't
worry about it one way or another let's
say this if you could take over the
Miami Dolphins yeah what would you want
to be your quarterback oh boy if you
could get a quarterback maybe right now
the quarterback was available what you
know a quarterback you're talking about
Oh would you lobby McCall don't get me
in trouble with everybody over here in
Kansas City right now man you know
okay okay all right so and
congratulations to the Chiefs
congratulations to the Diamonds me yeah
yeah yeah definitely
yeah and the Niners day they met me and
they came back from a rough season so ya
know they turn it around they turned it
around and the Chiefs boy
watch out how much preparation goes into
a Super Bowl performance what does it
take to do a Super Bowl before how much
preparation I wouldn't know to be honest
with you you know I just hear about all
the crazy things that Jennifer's going
through and Shakira's going through yeah
yeah no you can't have a Super Bowl in
the 305 without mr. 305
let's see once again in the felt thank
you for picking Miami we appreciate you
Jennifer besito Shakira besito
Feliciano means congratulations and
let's see what goes on what does it mean
to have those two ladies on that stage
though rapping that's sophisticated sexy
powerful hard-working diligent militant
and what I mean militant I mean they
just go and get it yeah I've opened a
lot of doors for someone such as myself
and I'm always proud to be around him
I'm always proud of them and what they
got going on and keep taking it to the
next level okay so listen it is great
having you here thanks for stopping by
I appreciate we will see you Sunday
we'll see you Sunday Sunday no I'm
talking about in one turn for the show
but see don't I'll see you on the field
Sunday
[Music]